on the 29th of November Elon Musk posted
this ominous tweet he was referring to
Apple at the time and at the time he was
waging an online war against them now
this was not the first time Apple would
go to war with other tech companies but
it was definitely the first time they
had to face a foe as formidable as Elon
Musk the world's richest man so what
exactly are we dealing with here what is
this war about and is there a chance
that the world's richest man will bring
the world's richest company to its knees
before Elon Musk Twitter came for Apple
there was epic games and before epic
games there was Facebook understanding
to Feud these other two companies had
and still currently have with apple will
help us understand how Apple got into a
jewel with Elon Musk and while elon's
tweet about the fruit company's
predatory 30 tax sets the pace for
everything wrong with the latter's
relationship with other tech companies
it barely scratches the surface this
Feud runs deeper than you think and as
you might have guessed already it has
everything to do with troll Facebook's
issue with apple began with privacy
while both companies are tech companies
on paper their business model and
revenue stream are decidedly different
Apple practically draws in all of its
revenue from the hardware itself with
the iPhone serving the largest slice
meanwhile Facebook relies predominantly
on targeted advertising and this is
where the problem between Zuckerberg and
Tim Cook began apple is extremely strict
with the privacy of their software and
its users it's one of the reasons why
they run a closed ecosystem and why they
haven't had as many security issues as
Google's Android this policy had always
been inconvenient for Facebook who in
the past teamed up with HTC to build a
Facebook phone the device died a
miserable death the real trouble began
in 2018 in the wake of the Cambridge
analytica Scandal which exposed the
widespread collection and misuse of
personal data by third-party app
developers on Facebook Tim Cook
requested Facebook to delete whatever
data they had collected from consumers
but Zuckerberg declined so in the years
they followed Apple implemented a series
of changes to its operating system and
in its App Store that eventually made it
exponentially harder for app developers
to access users personal data without
their explicit consent Facebook
interpreted this as a direct attack on
their business for obvious reasons and
Mark Zuckerberg even issued a statement
publicly criticizing Apple's changes
arguing that they would hurt small
businesses and consequently stifle
innovation did Facebook's business
really suffer the answer is yes recent
years have seen them move from their
original business model towards the
metaverse they even went as far as
rebranding from Facebook to meta and
they've invested billions in Virtual and
augmented reality hardware for what they
anticipate to be a new frontier of the
internet if they control the hardware in
this new frontier then they do not have
to bother about Apple and its
restrictive policies now in the
background of this Feud Apple was
fighting another bitter war with a
completely different tech company enter
epic games this video made by epic games
was the ultimate in insult a revision of
Apple's 1984 ad that reframed apple as
the Big Brother villain which had
previously been IBM funnily enough
things weren't always this way because
unlike Facebook epic games had a healthy
relationship with apple in the beginning
in fact they worked together and there's
a new game that's going to be coming out
later this year
that we saw that's really remarkable
from epic games and it's it's my great
pleasure to invite on stage Mike Capps
the president of epic games to show us
this amazing new game using Game Center
from then on until the dissolution of
their relationship in 2017 epic was
featured at several other Apple product
launches and was often highlighted on
the App Store Apple even says they spent
one million dollars marketing games for
epic so you can imagine how shocked they
were when epic game CEO and co-founder
Tim Sweeney began publicly criticizing
Apple's payment system claiming that 30
tax on sales was unfair but epic games
had accepted this policy for almost a
decade so what changed it's unclear but
what is clear is that by 2020 after
years of Apple resisting their demand
epic introduced a direct payment system
in its fortnite app that allowed players
to make in-game purchases without going
through Apple's App Store and apple
responded by removing the fortnite app
from its app store which in turn
prompted epic games to file a lawsuit
against Apple alleging that its
practices were anti-competitive violated
Federal Anti-Trust laws and ultimately
hurt small businesses small businesses
Apple defended Itself by arguing that
its payment system was necessary to
maintain a safe and secure app ecosystem
at the end of it all Epic Games lost the
case which wasn't shocking however the
damage was done the validity of a 30 tax
now had a question mark in the court of
public opinion now every developer aside
from Google began to question why they
had to pay Apple that much and it is at
this point that Elon Musk enters the
conversation Elon has never really been
the biggest fan of post Steve Jobs Apple
he's been vocal and highly critical of
the company's Direction often citing a
lack of innovation in their devices and
his primary platform for expressing his
discontent has been Twitter despite all
of this Elon has never really confronted
apple or to be more precise he has never
really had a reason to until he acquired
Twitter in one of the messiest and
highly publicized corporate deals of the
decade Aid what started off as a joke
became almost a year-long back and forth
litigation riddled tug of war between
musk and the bird company that
ultimately led to his acquisition of the
latter for a ridiculous 44 billion
dollars everyone agreed that the company
was overpriced Elon himself even
admitted it in this tweet from May where
he essentially claimed that the company
was riddled with Bots and not as
profitable as it said it was and even
though Elon has been quoted saying that
he doesn't care for the economics of
Twitter he has since realized that for
Twitter to work the way he wants it to
the company first has to be profitable
unfortunately Twitter wasn't and still
isn't in a state where it can recoup
elon's multi-billion investment well I
want you to take a look at this chart
that shows different social media market
share do you see elon's Twitter now
compare that with say Instagram or even
LinkedIn now take into consideration
that we are in a recession and the
advertising industry has been taking hit
after hit but wait it gets worse in an
attempt to monetize Twitter and rid the
platform of bots Elon Musk introduce
some changes that didn't go down well
with many users and businesses on the
platform like the short-lived Eight
dollar blue check Fiasco that led to a
spike in impersonations and false tweets
being attributed to real companies which
allegedly led to a drop in many of these
companies stock prices and around this
time Elon Musk publish this tweet on the
28th of November 2022 Elon Musk publicly
called out Apple for stopping its
advertising on the social media platform
implying that Apple hated Free Speech
some hours later he published another
tweet that implied that apple had
threatened to withhold Twitter from its
app stores but wouldn't tell him why but
Apple was not the only one turning the
heat on elon's Twitter according to user
at unusual dogs Elon lost 50 of
Twitter's leading 100 top advertisers
the advertisers in question have
reportedly accounted for over 2 billion
US dollars in spending on the platform
since 2020 and over 750 million US
dollars in advertising in 2022 alone but
advertising wasn't the only focus of
elon's online battle with apple in this
tweet clearly directed at the smartphone
giant Elon uses a meme to make his point
about the Apple tax on third-party apps
in their ecosystem in a different tweet
just below he even asked his audience
did you know Apple puts a secret 30 tax
on everything you buy through their App
Store according to musk this is 10 times
higher than it normally should be he
even called out Tim Cook tagging him in
this tweet apple is also threatening to
withhold Twitter from its App Store but
won't tell us why what's going on here
at Tim Cook fortnite was removed from
the App Store was the same thing going
to happen to Twitter this was the
question everyone was asking soon there
were talks about a Tesla phone through
all of this apple didn't react or
respond but that didn't stop Musk from
rallying the supporters of users who
chip their two cents into the feud when
one user asked is Apple threatening
Twitter's presence in the app store or
otherwise making moderation demands
elon's answer was yes then Elon began
asking everyone who else has Apple
censored this was a direct accusation
that cast CEO Tim Cook patrons of
censorship in America while positioning
himself as the leader of the Revolution
against the Tech Giant now it's easy to
forget that Twitter was not the only
Elon Ned company caught in the middle of
this mostly one-sided War Tesla users
were concerned and many even begged him
to take a step back from public matters
for their sake but when one Tesla user
asked is this really a fight we want to
pick an awful lot of your Tesla
customers use iOS to access their cars
if that app gets pulled it'll
significantly impact your ability to
sell to Apple customers cards are way
less convenient than BT entry elon's
response was sarcastic at best on the
1st of December Elon posted this video
with the caption thanks at Tim Cook for
taking me around Apple's beautiful
headquarters apparently Tim Cook had
made peace with Elon by inviting him to
Cupertino for a tour under the same
tweet Elon published another one where
he clarified some issues Apple had with
Twitter good conversation among other
things we resolve the misunderstanding
about Twitter potentially being removed
from the App Store Tim was clear that
apple never considered doing so but
there is still one issue that hasn't
been settled the 30 cut obviously Apple
hasn't Exempted Twitter from the tax and
it's unlikely that they will do so
anytime soon especially since epic games
has appealed the same case they lost so
is this a false Piece Will Elon Musk in
all his eccentricity step back from his
war of tweets against apple or is this
the beginning of a cordial relationship
between the blue bird and the Apple
company for now only time will tell and
in the world of the world's richest and
most powerful there's more than enough
of that to go around